mohamed garne est français mais il est
français par un viol un viol perpétré
sur sa mère en août 1959
sans doute par des militaires français
d'ailleurs les documents officiels le
reconnaissent maintenant
mohamed garne a longtemps cherché à
retrouver sa mère et dia finalement
réussi mais maintenant il veut obtenir
pour être en paix avec sa mémoire une
réparation de l'état français pour ce
crime dont il est née agnès vahramian et
jean luc boussard ont rencontré mohamed
garne c'est l'histoire d'une quête d'un
orphelin d'algérie à la recherche de ses
parents sur l'acte de naissance de
mohamed garne le nom et le prénom de sa
mère qu'elle ira il la retrouve à alger
c'était il ya six ans elle lui confie
qu'il est né d'un viol par des
militaires français
elle lui raconte sa capture en 59 elle
avait 14 ans et demi vous savez ce que
c'est la peur d'une enfant sur un arbre
en train de trembler une guerre des
bombes qui tombent de l'autre côté une
enfant qui n'a rien à voir avec la
guerre et on la trappe
on l'a fait descendre le camp est une
belle femme ma mère était une belle
fille c'était une enfant mais toutefois
l'avoir violée qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
keira est séparé très vite de son enfant
dans le camp de regroupement de civils
elle sert de bonne à tout faire et
maltraités elle perd la raison mendiante
elle vit aujourd'hui dans un cimetière
d'alger elle ne sortira pas de ce
cimetière pourquoi elle aime vivre avec
les morts la cicatrice ne s'est pas
encore refermée comme elle dit elle
disait mieux vivre avec les morts et ne
me touche pas à mon fils mohamed garne
sera lui placé par les autorités
françaises à l'orphelinat
nous sommes en pleine guerre d'algérie
une enfance perturbée une adolescence
décousu à 40 ans il ne veut plus avoir
mon père vous avez c'est un pauvre type
celui qui a fait ça qu'est ce que je
vais faire je vais chercher qui est mon
père voulu dire la rapidité à papa c'est
au café ça non
c'est je perdais mon temps mohamed garne
demandent à être reconnus comme victimes
civiles de la guerre d'algérie il sait
bien qu'aucune guerre n'est propre
il n'est pas indigne j'ai envie de
refaire ma vie c'est tout refaire ma vie
oublier tout ça mais pour oublier tout
ça il faut que je combat pour la vérité
comme ça je ne vais pas devenir une
autre personne qui va encore oublié et
faire oublier ce qui s'est passé dans
ses jugements
la justice française admet qu'il y avait
eu viols mais pour l mohamed garne est
une victime indirecte de la guerre et ne
peut à ce titre toucher une pension lui
et son avocat n'en font pas une affaire
d'argent
mohamed garne vit avec ses enfants
travaillent aujourd'hui dans ce qui est
aussi son pays la france